Aaron came up in the ocean you might be
ready to say goodbye to Keeping Up with
the Kardashians where are you at on that
um I'm just decided to spend more time
as a mom and you know put more of my
energy there but I'm not saying goodbye
but I think you'll have to see more of
it on the new season season 18 crazy
isn't airing yet but it's being filmed
okay and currently do you want in this
room do you think the show can continue
going if you lose a sister yeah I mean
we definitely love Courtney and we will
miss Courtney and whatever she decides
to do but people come people go all the
time this family we are feel like it's a
revolving door so Kourt you might leave
this week she'll be back they all come
back we can do another spin-off just Kim
and Chloe take take Calabasas amazing
it's just given I can live in the condo
with all of our kids and see how that
goes
this sounds like a show to me not for me
I love doing collabs with my sisters it
makes me feel kind of nostalgic to me
this is a no-brainer to do a collab with
Kourtney and khloé so describe like the
different smells for each one and why
that you think that kind of goes with
your personalities or your vibes well
mine is actually very sweet mine's
Jasmine lilac and sue burrows are like
their main sense but mine is just my
signature scent it's something that I've
always been drawn to they're my
favorites notes and I'm to combine them
all and have they work really well in
your natural body oils so I love them if
you know us you smell Kourtney's and
it's like oh my god this is Kourtney
if you smell mine you're like oh my god
this is mine I can smell mine just to
realize because I you need a mood lifter
[Music]